I know that sometimes when you're family
things get heated cuz I know I'm on the
voice okay we gotta heat it on the voice
to all the coach we love each other were
like brothers and sisters so I know we
are we are seriously and literally it
kind of can bleed on stage did y'all
ever get in like an argument you're like
it's you're not coming back from did you
ever do that no kidding how much you're
so great together the key don't even
start with the first day hey I have been
the only girl in a panel and it is hard
true and they always use you as like the
ditzy thing seems like y'all are really
friendly but I do that this is my
actually one of my coolest things my
connection with you rainy is you
introduce me to somebody that changed my
life and my career and I kind of cause I
stole him from Justin but you somebody
here wants to say something because I
have been working with my musical
director Jason Halbert since I know you
put the band together and you put you
put him in my path and I just wanted to
give him in he wanted to tell you
something
you probably don't know this but we met
18 years ago and you were out with
Destiny's Child and I was on tour we
were opening up and I just wanted a
picture with Beyonce that to be honest
uh I knocked on the dressing-room door
and walk in the door I was so nervous I
hand the camera to this dude who was you
and we talked in the hallway afterwards
you asked me for my phone number yeah
[Laughter]
and never heard from you
eight months
eight months later out of the blue I
just take another job and you call me up
and he said I just finished the show
called American Idol and I called my
wife and she's like take the job because
she had been voting for for Kelly but
you have no idea how many cameramen
producers people behind the scenes these
musicians and you set them up it's
always about paying it forward right and
Jason I'm so happy to see him here I'm
happy to see Jessie here singing back
[Applause]
[Laughter]
some new projects you're working on I've
got this company called unify health
labs it's a whole health wellness kind
of company to have come up with vitamins
in the next month yeah managing a ton of
writers and producers and artists and
chefs god they're like the glasses
anyone can wear that's awesome and also
I wanted to mention Pollan we saw each
other at the billboards you couldn't
hear us because you're all out there
being another word I can't see on TV
now when you fell from the copy I was
like I'm like I wouldn't do that now
like who killed it you made
[Applause]
okay that's how that's done like that
was it was no great so what are you up
to right now
well i have i just opened a residency in
las vegas hey mister you me like a
thousand shows like what are you working
on what give me the CliffsNotes what's
happening right now
I know America's Got Talent yeah we're
doing that I found being honest with you
this does make me think if I had one
wish it would be to make another show
with us again that would be my own the
fact that we had so much fun and we and
look to credit you Kelly like I said we
wouldn't be here without you the fact
that you are I mean one of the most
successful singers in the world I have
to say something about you Kelly unlike
the majority you are the same person
off camera and absolutely thrilled for
you genuine you deserve everything
you've worked hard for and for you these
guys even though everyone remembers all
the craziness what worked about that
series was is that Randi like myself is
an A&R card but he was also a record
producer Paula
actually was a brilliant spotter of
talent I was an A&R guy in there which
meant I did it which is one of the
reasons why I think we had an and this
additional chemistry so our legacy
genuinely were are the artists we you
know starting with you who we discovered
over like this seven-year period and
that's what I'm most proud of I mean the
show's ratings great that's one thing
but it's who came through the process is
made it all worthwhile
and that's why genuinely if I if I could
choose who to work with all over again I
would work with these guys again I will
not stop talking until you subscribe to
my youtube channel that's right and I
could talk a lot seriously not gonna
stop yep still here not going anywhere I
see you don't walk away from this